[Music]
my
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning everyone and welcome to
this year's digital edition
of the brussels economic forum we're
coming to you live
from the television studios of the
european commission's berlin
headquarters
in brussels i'm maria tadeo from
bloomberg
and today i have the pleasure to guide
you through
our numerous and i'm sure lively
discussions about the european
economic and social agenda now this year
is special for more than one reason not
only because this is the first time we
have
a fully digital event that's due to the
special circumstances created by the
coronavirus pandemic but also because
this is the 20th anniversary edition
of the brussels economic forum now we do
hope to retain the best element of the
brussels economic forum and that is
the quality of our speakers and the
debate and that this new format will
allow you
to join our debate online the 20th
anniversary edition of the brussels
economic forum does
give us an opportunity to look back at
the past 20 years of economic history
since the year 2000 and to think about
where we want to shape
the economy of the future therefore i
would like to ask you to go
back in time on a journey through the
key economic milestones of the last
20 years and to look back at some of the
speakers that we've had here
of the brussels economic forum over the
past 20 years
[Music]
[Music]
and that's quite a few familiar faces i
spotted there who have joined us here at
the brussels economic forum
over the past 20 years some of whom i'm
pleased to say will be joining us
again this year now today's digital
event
will last until lunchtime and we'll try
to get a better understanding
of the future of the economy in a
post-pandemic world
and of course we will be looking at the
economic angle here
but in line with the traditional spirit
of the brussels economic forum
we also want to take a broader
perspective
and discuss the challenges and
opportunities in terms of
the politics society globalization
and trade and it's still incredible to
think just how much
our lives have changed in just the last
six months and as you know this has been
a crisis of historic
proportions even bigger than the
financial crisis
of the last decade and despite the
rebound
economic output in the european union is
unlikely to return to pre-crisis levels
by the end of the next year this crisis
has
affected all countries and people across
the world
although some clearly have been hit
harder than others
in the second quarter of 2020 that saw
the worst
quarterly drop in the eu gdp since the
second
world war that's 11.7 percent
in today's event we will discuss not
just how to
support countries businesses and people
so they emerge stronger from the crisis
but also how the coronavirus has already
transformed
our lives and economies we do hope
you'll enjoy it
and you'll come out of this with a
clearer picture of the path
ahead we want to make this event as
interactive as possible so i do
encourage everyone of you that's
watching online
to participate remember you can send in
your questions or vote on
other people questions on slido with the
code
eubef20 and you will
also be invited to vote during the event
to ask questions you can head to the bef
website or type slido that is s
l i dot d o in the
website browser of your phone or your
tablet
and for those joining on twitter and i
know there's many of you on twitter
please do use our hashtag eubef20
and without much further ado allow me to
introduce our first speaker of the day
nadia calvino she is spain's third
deputy prime minister
a minister of economic affairs and
digital transformation
she is joining us from madrid
deputy prime minister calvino has been
an outspoken
advocate of an ambitious recovery plan
for the european union
and has steered spain's economy through
the economic crisis
sparked by the pandemic we're very happy
to have her as her
opening keynote speaker and of course to
hear
her perspective on how to relaunch the
eu
economy minister
good morning it's a great pleasure for
me to take part in the brussels economic
forum again
this year i think it's really important
that this flagship conference takes
place
and the timing is perfect as the coming
months will be absolutely key in shaping
the future of europe
so warm congratulations to the
organizers
in order to set the scene of the very
intense and high quality program ahead
let me share some thoughts on the
current situation and economic outlook
little did we know when we met at flaget
in june last year to discuss a new
agenda for europe
that just some months later we would
find ourselves in a completely different
reality
which would turn upside down many of the
assumptions underlying our forecasts and
plans
it has in fact been almost half a year
now since the virus
hit europe and lockdown measures were
adopted in most member states
our countries are going through
unprecedented times the pandemic is
having a terrible impact in terms of
human lives
and we are facing very complex
challenges
learning the lessons from the past this
time around i think that europe has
stood up to the challenge and put in
place in record time
a very strong response not only on the
sanitary front but also to preserve
our economies and our societies and to
ensure a fast recovery
it is clear that the fight against the
pandemic is not over and the currency
economic situation is still marked by
very high uncertainty
we still have difficult times ahead but
thanks to the intense work
undertaken from day one at the national
and european level
we have come a long way in shaping the
economic response to the crisis
in the first instance we acted to ensure
financial stability
to protect liquidity flows to the whole
economy to minimize the damage in labor
markets and to preserve household income
this phase can be described as one of
resistance
this fast and coordinated response has
been key i think to protect a solid
basis on which to build the recovery
and avoid a more structural and
long-standing damage which would have
been much more difficult to heal
to give you some examples in spain we
increased
the flexibility and public support for
short-term work schemes
a mechanism which had not worked in the
country before and is proving this time
around
to be extremely effective to protect
more than 3 million jobs
avoiding the massive layoffs which took
place in previous much less intense
economic downturns we also activated a
100 billion euros public guarantee line
that has already mobilized almost that
amount in credit
mostly benefiting small and medium-sized
moreover we created a new specific
allowance to protect more than one
million self-employed workers affected
by the lockdown
these measures adopted in the first
stage in spain amount to around four
percent of gdp in additional expenditure
and 10
of gdp in liquidity but beyond these
numbers
the country factual is one of very
serious economic damage
not to speak of the social implications
we estimate
that spain's gdp would have fallen by 25
in 2020 and 3 million jobs would have
been lost
without this emergency action there are
of course differences
on the size of the support granted by
the different member states
but looking at figures it is clear that
we have all carried out an
unprecedented fiscal effort in parallel
with actions at national level we
started to work together on the european
response
the sheer size of this crisis that knows
no borders
requires joint action tribute must be
paid
to all european institutions starting
with the european central bank
which has ensured financial stability
and there by
enabled national governments to adopt
emergency measures
all european institutions acted fast and
i think that their initiative has been
instrumental
to the progress we have made in a matter
of weeks
the temporary state aid framework the
coronavirus response investment
initiative
the new short-term liquidity instruments
put in place by the commission
the eib and the esm to create a triple
safety net for companies governments and
workers
have been essential to ensure
appropriate funding conditions and also
to provide
certainty certainty is probably the most
precious asset
in times of turbulence amongst these
instruments
let me highlight sure which for the
first time provides support for
short-term work schemes and therefore
targets employment protection a backstop
for the people
as we gradually started reopening our
economies in may the situation started
to improve
in spain all available indicators
confirmed that there was a turning point
in may and we have moved since then to
the second phase
marked by reactivation if we continue to
control the spread of the virus we are
confident that the recovery will take
the shape of an asymmetric
v leading to very strong growth in 2021.
our forecast as well as those of the
independent fiscal authority and other
analysts
point at gdp growth above 10
already in the third quarter of the
current year
in order to support business reopening
economic activity resuming and new job
creation
we adjusted in the course of june and
july the different measures put in place
we fine-tuned short-term work schemes to
incentivize
workers return to their jobs we have
turned our focus through solvency on top
of liquidity
with a new public guarantee for
investment as well as new instruments to
provide capital support to strategic
companies
we have adopted specific sector support
programs for those most affected such as
tourism
transport or the auto industry in
parallel
unprecedented steps were taken to lay
the foundation for a robust european
response
also for the wrong long run i am
referring of course to the adoption of
the 2021-2027 multi-annual financial
framework
and the recovery plan for europe the
commission's next generation eu proposal
was
up to the challenge and eventually led
to the historical agreement of the
european council in july
from the very beginning spain had been
calling for a european response
so that we could emerge stronger from
the crisis
we have put forward a number of
proposals and played and actively
constructive role
which i hope contributed to facilitating
and shaping
the final agreement reached after many
long hours of work and discussion
i am sure other speakers will talk more
in depth about the agreement
but i would really like to highlight
this as a very positive a truly
historical step for the future of the
union
it is a european response funded with
european debts
we will borrow to invest in our common
future
it is commensurate to the challenge 750
billion
euros on top of the mff it's focused on
grants an absolutely indispensable
element to prevent
that excessive debt burdens at national
level hinder investment and future
growth
and with a special focus on the most
affected member states
we have achieved key milestone
but much remains to be done we are still
fighting against the pandemic
although this second wave is so far much
less damaging in terms of public health
and death levels
the full economic impact will still
continue to unfold
for some months as some sectors are
still affected by the drop
of domestic and global demand this
crisis
is accelerating some trends which were
already visible
but have become a reality in a matter of
weeks
digitalization is a clear example which
has confirmed the strength of our
networks
but also exposed the risk of social gaps
and rising inequality if we do not act
fast
starting with our schooling systems
adjusting to these new realities has
become urgent if we want to ensure that
the recovery reaches
every region that no one is left behind
so we need to work hard to implement as
soon as possible the national investment
and reform plans and to activate
the much needed european recovery
funding we need to be efficient and
agile in order to ensure that the
economic recovery is strong
and sustainable from the financial
environmental
and social point of view with every
challenge comes an opportunity and this
time i think we do
have a clear plan to seize it to
accelerate the transformation of our
economies
and to do it together from the national
perspective we are committed to making
the best use of the resources coming
from next generation eu
we are working on a national recovery
transformation and resilience plan
carrying out a careful exercise of
prioritization to ensure the resources
are used
to promote the transformation processes
that the spanish economy needs
the plan will comprise an ambitious
agenda of investments and structural
reforms
aligned to the priorities of the eu and
the european semester recommendations
with four key access green transition
digital transformation social and
territorial cohesion and closing the
gender gap
we will seek to achieve the maximum
possible social and political support at
home
working with the private sector the
regions and municipalities and social
partners
we are determined to act fast and move
quickly towards the third
and next stage the recovery implementing
the recovery plan will be a top priority
for all of us in the coming months
but we should not forget about many
other issues that continue to be
essential at the european level
such as completing the banking union and
the capital markets union and moving
forward with
fair and effective taxation including
the digital tax
it is clear that the road ahead is still
long and full of uncertainties which i
am sure will be discussed at length
today so let me close this introductory
statement with two final thoughts on the
outlook for the next 12 months
first economic forecasting is almost
mission impossible but there are a
couple of anchors to guide us beyond
figures
our focus should be on kickstarting
growth and job creation as soon as
possible
we should make sure that investment is
protected and we must act fast and
decisively
for our actions today will certainly
shape the future of europe
and secondly we have more than ever be
made aware
that we are on the same boat so we
better keep working together to deliver
a stronger europe
well-equipped for the future and able to
bring solutions and prosperity today
and for generations to come let me close
on this forward-looking note
i wish you all the best for the upcoming
discussions at the forum today
i look forward to seeing you in person
soon
thank you very much
well thank you very much uh deputy prime
minister cavina who is joining us
from madrid that was an interesting
perspective which
takes us perfectly to the next topic of
our session now i'm happy to say i'm
joined here
in the studio by the executive vice
president valdez
dombrovskis who will kick off our
discussion together with
our panelists that i will introduce in
just
a moment and we'll be looking at what
the new european economy could look like
after the coronavirus and without a
doubt
the world will be a very different place
after the pandemic
not just from a strictly economic
perspective
but also from a social and geopolitical
viewpoint
in this discussion we'll be hoping to or
looking at the economic ramifications of
the pandemic and
we'll also look into how we can address
the impact of the coronavirus on
inequality
poverty and joblessness these are
consequences of course that have been
particularly harsh
among the most vulnerable sectors of
society especially
young people already hit hard by the
previous crisis
and let's not forget what this means in
terms of the geopolitics
trade and europe's relations with the
rest of the world
and in the meantime before we start i do
want to remind you that you can get in
your questions you can do that on
twitter
on slido use the hashtag eubef20
but right now i'm delighted to bring in
valdes dembrovsky's executive
vice president of the european union and
the commission
for an economy that works for people and
he will introduce our opening remarks
for our discussions
so thank you uh maria good morning
so uh first of all i would like to thank
you for this uh
invitation on the uh 20's brussels
economic
forum so um slowly and
cautiously many eu countries are
emerging from what was hopefully the
worst of the crisis
but the pandemic is far from over we
will be navigating through stormy waters
for some time
what europe needs now is strong and
inclusive recovery
for everyone in all our countries
this is objective of the eu's recovery
package
to to be a ship that keeps afloat in
rough seas
and gets us through the storm for that
we need a ship with a powerful
engine our recovery package is worth a
combined
1.82 trillion euros
based on 750 billion euros from next
generation on you
on top of a reinforced eu budget for the
next
seven years the engine's driving force
is a recovery
and resilience facility it can it
combines
312.5 billion euros in grants
and up to 360 billion in loans
to support reforms and investments
undertaken by national governments
the funding is dedicated uh mainly to
making our economies more resilient
and investing uh for jobs and growth in
green
and digital recovery so
what is the next step before our ship
can do its work
those countries that want to draw as a
facility
should set out their reform and reform
agendas
reform and investment agendas for next
four years
and submit these plans to the commission
later this month will provide more
detail on the next steps
here we should think of projects with a
common european
interest as a facility will finance
reforms and investments that
fit with the european priorities and
specific
challenges as set out in the european
semester
the aim is not to take us back where we
were before the crisis
but to invest in europe's generations to
come
this is a chance to do things better to
make our economy more inclusive
and resilience to uh resilient to future
shocks and to
rebuild convergence across eu countries
uh one area to watch in is an even pace
of the economic recovery
the crisis is affecting companies and
workers very differently depending on
their activity and location
we are looking at how to support
companies and workers
given changing realities such as again
green and digital transitions
in order not to leave anyone behind we
will have to invest in skills
development
and we will work to close existing
economic social and territorial
inequalities as much as possible
our economic recovery should be as fair
even and
inclusive as it as we can make it the
european pillar of social rights remains
our compass for this
and we are working on action plan to
implement it
the national plans should uh aim to
raise productivity growth
with investments and uh in
infrastructure and human
capital and reforms to facilitate
structural shifts and
also to help workers to adjust
at the time like this it's important to
preserve the integrity of the single
market
it is the best asset for our ship to
steer
us through those rough seas
ladies and gentlemen when the commission
entered office
we presented our goals of making
europe's economy greener and
more digital the crisis has not changed
these ambitions
in fact the profound socio-economic
impact means that it's more
urgent to act the green and digital
transitions
hold the key to europe's future
prosperity
as you may know i had been working a
great deal to promote sustainable
finance and green investments to help
europe reach the goal of carbon
neutrality
we need to push ahead with energy
efficiency projects electromobility
renewable energies hydrogen and much
more
the financing and investment decisions
that we are taking now
will have significant impact on
greenhouse gas emissions in the next
decades
to take full advantage of digital
opportunities we need to improve
connectivity across europe build a real
data economy
and invest in new technologies like
artificial intelligence
robotics and the internet of things
this is how we can increase the eu's
competitiveness and resilience
as well as create new sources of
revenues and jobs
all this comes with a hefty price tag of
course
at the same time national coffers are
depleted after
dealing with a pandemic and government
debts across europe have
reached record levels the public sector
is doing what it can to help
the eu's recovery package earmarks 30
percent of funds
to support our climate objectives
it is the highest share of largest
european budget ever awarded
but a public money on its own will not
be enough
we also need large-scale and
forward-looking investments from the
private sector
to help stimulate the funding i will
present a green finance action plan in
the coming months
both transitions imply unprecedented
modernization and
transformation across the board
widespread restructuring
and industrial change in all sectors
these are areas where martin sanbu and
maya gupper have
great deal of knowledge and expertise
and i look forward
joining them on the panel shortly ladies
and gentlemen
europe is in a brink of massive change
and opportunity too
the recovery package especially the
recovery and resilience facility
allows us our countries to uh recover
from the crisis and to embrace the
future
now we need to make sure that it's uh
what is
that it's properly put into effect so
that our ship of recovery can
set sail as soon as possible this is
time for looking forward and
not back we need to weather the storm
and come
out to other side stronger stronger
thank you well vice president thank you
for that
and at this point uh do stay with us
because our next panel
discussion begins next
[Music]
now let me introduce the other two
speakers that are joining us from remote
locations for this
panel discussion this morning here at
the brussels economic forum
first we have martin sandbu who is the
financial times
european economics commentator he is
joining us from
london now martin is one of the most
experienced commentators on the
economics of the euro area and has just
authored a book called the economics of
belonging
which looks into the causes behind the
search
and populism over the last decade
joining us from berlin is
maya gurple she is secretary general of
the german advisory council
of global change maya is a defender of
new prosperity models
as best described in her book the great
mind shift
now to kick off this uh discussion i do
want to begin
with a brief opening question to our two
speakers
when you look at europe at this point 19
of europeans will tell you
they believe the europe economy will
emerge
stronger from this crisis but that's
just 19 of them
so how can we make sure that we can
build something that is better that is
more inclusive
for european citizens maya let's kick
off
with you
good morning to brussels good morning mr
dombrowskis good morning mrs sambu
i'm very happy about a remote
conversation it's quite a new experience
i do uh think i would like to tail on a
few things that were already mentioned
in the opening speech and that is that
we should be very cognizant
that the model of development that we
had before corona hit
was not a good one i mean in january
only we had at the world economic forum
the global risk report pointing out
in particular environmental change to be
at the top
risks of hampering prosperity in the
future so we've been basically having a
world risk society
at our hands before we even entered the
corona crisis
and i think joseph stiglitz put it
together really nicely when his book
came out on beyond gdp
in december of last year that we do have
a climate crisis
we do have a democracy crisis we do have
an inequality crisis
but we are following lead indicators in
economics that don't give us a hint that
we could have a problem
and this is where i think we have to
open up the story and open up
the framework with which we're
benchmarking our development
because the story of growth will benefit
everybody and
will be possible in continuation of one
planet
had been broken before and now we have a
really really good opportunity
when we disaggregate the data with which
we measure when we become much more
clear on what we want to deliver
on the jobs that are bringing well-being
improving health
and restoring our ecosystem so that we
have stability
and security and prosperity in europe
and the rest of the world
to be the future with which we can
leapfrog so i really think we should use
the opportunity now
because we do have to change a lot of
the path dependencies that we've been
finding difficult to break out of before
the corona crisis and now they're open
to change anyway we've heard that the
macroeconomics is more of a crystal ball
right now
than anything that is predictable um in
a reliable way
and so to really take the opportunity to
make sure that we're very clear on
saying what we want to achieve
and to go into measuring that and making
that transparent and making it the new
narrative
of europe so a green and social deal
for me seems to be the promise with
which we can guide
the covered recovery packages to meet
people where they are
and to take into consideration the
concerns especially also on the
connection between health
and our environment as the eea reports
only today
have shown again with regard to
pollution and the health impacts
that come from it thank you so maya
green social deal and now i want to ask
that same question
to martin do we need a new model and how
can we do it
well you pointed out good morning first
greetings from london
you pointed out that only 19 of
europeans feel good or optimistic about
the economy the best way to make people
confident about the economy
is to make the economy strong it's a
simple message but we actually have to
do the work so i think you know two
overarching principles are important
here before we get into all the details
so one is that
the people of europe need to feel that
the policy makers
have their back and to be fair
governments and the eu as a whole have
done a good job in trying to protect
people from the fallout
of the pandemic but it's crucial now i
think that we build on that
and don't fall into the trap that we
fell into in the previous crisis
and remove support from the economy too
soon it's really crucial to keep
strong demand growth up as we go into
the next year the second thing and here
i want to echo some of what maya was
saying
is that people need to hear that there's
an awareness
at the top that we should not just
rebuild but rebuild
better and it can't just be the words it
has to be
the action so of course we need to see
that the opportunities taken from this
disruption to reorient our economy in
further in the green direction but also
socially
we need to remember that those who have
been hit hardest
health-wise but in particular
economically by the pandemic
we're the people who are already
struggling the most
in the imperfect economies we have in
europe people
in precarious work unpredictable work
often underpaid work those are the ones
who
lost their jobs and lost their
livelihoods in the worst of the
lockdowns and still face the biggest
uncertainty
to come so it needs to be very clear and
not just in words but in action and in
results on the ground
that these people who are already
drawing the shortest straw of economic
change
are now going to be taken care of well
martin thank you so much for that
and i do want to now start with the q a
and please feel free to interact
with each other and of course if you're
watching this to send in your questions
the hashtag of course is eubf2020 and
maya i want to kick off with you
and look into the future the next
generation eu budget
of course a central part of that will be
climate
climate change and how to get on those
very ambitious targets
do you worry however because of the
short-term economic
impact of the corona crisis that we
could see backtracking of that become
less ambitious on those targets
obviously that is the center of the
debate right now and i do
think that it is very very crucial to
make sure that we are showing what the
ambitions are and
why it is a win-win situation if we're
really tying in
solving the problems that we had
identified before by using the money
that we now have to put in place out of
the public pockets
to create the kind of jobs we need to
make the transition that mr dembroskis
was talking about the greening of the
economy
and the digitalization to really put
that as a service
of a sustainable development model and
to be very clear also on the statistics
because there have been a lot of reports
showing
that especially in the renewable energy
sector for example there will be
many more jobs if we go for a
decentralized and renewable energy
system
rather than with a centralized one that
we had right now there are similar
endeavors looking at the promotion of
jobs in comparison to what we have right
now in a linear
way of using our resources from a
circular economy
where we're going into having to reshape
business models from
just selling and then waiting until it's
in the dump in the fill
and then maybe recycling some of the
resources into looking at what can be
sharing economy and business models that
we're much more leasing
and using the same kind of hardware or
infrastructure
for delivery on human need satisfaction
for multiple people instead of all of us
storing a lot of things in our basements
taking up a lot of resources that we
hardly ever use
so whole circularity building into the
economy
can create a lot of new jobs and this is
why i think it
is very crucial not only to look at who
might lose which is obviously
the stronger impact because often those
business models are also
well connected to the current um
administrations to the media and have
the surplus money to also make their
voices heard in the public but i do
remember very strongly janice petrochenk
saying uh clearly when we were talking
about resource efficiency package some
10 years ago that the losers shout
louder and it must be
the role of media and of civil society
but also of the companies themselves
and of politicians to show what can grow
when we're actually
looking at structural change and i was
just naming the two sectors i think
agriculture would be another one where
it's really high important
highly important to act sooner rather
than later because all of the economic
models that are looking at the costs of
further environmental destruction
show that it is much better also purely
economically
speaking to protect biodiversity to
ensure we're avoiding
climate catastrophe so all of those
benchmarks all of those calculations of
crop benefit and the job creation
impetuses that come with it and the
health benefits
need to be put firmly at the center of
the calculations
of what makes sense to invest in right
now and the emphasis on workers
on re-skilling on future proofing our
education system i can only second
but we've had these conversations as
well because of the digital revolution
that's taking place anyhow
and it is very affirming i find when you
look at the skills of the 21st century
that are being requested
from agents like the world economic
forum and businesses with regard to
systems thinking anticipation emotional
intelligence
critical thinking etc for delivering on
much more complex systems of working and
new technologies
with what the sustainable development
education agenda had been putting
forward
already for people to be able to
understand the linkages between the
social the economic the environmental
and the constant binding back of every
activity that humans are undertaking
with the possibilities of our planet to
replenish
the kind of resources we need in the
future so with all of this
endeavor to really really show the
linkages i feel that we should be able
to avoid the backtrack
but it does mean facing structural
change and to look at this as an
opportunity where a lot of public money
is needed anyway
a lot of support and direct support we
heard about the grand schemes
to really unlock the path dependencies
that were already
called out before corona as not being
helpful as not being sustainable
and to really take this crisis also as
an opportunity
and speaking of public money of course
the other big pillar to this recovery we
talked about the european commission but
the other one is the european central
bank
and martin i know that you recently
wrote about this and you suggested
perhaps that it's time for the ecb
to think about a new mandate what should
the new mandate
look like
look i think we need to think of fiscal
policy and monetary policy together
their job
is to stabilize or sustain demand growth
in the economy
and that is crucial let me give credit
where credit is to you the ecb
and also the eu institutions and
national governments have
gone to unprecedented lengths to support
demand
in this crisis but i still think we need
to worry
that they will do too little rather than
worry about them doing too much
partly because we really need to learn
from the last crisis
where the ecb turned to tightening
budgetary policy makers turned to fiscal
consolidation
far too soon and caused a second
recession let's not make that
mistake again the the federal reserve in
the u.s
just changed its mandate by saying look
we realize
that when we get close to what looks
like full employment
that is good because it drags people
into the labor market people who are
previously on the margin
that includes young people who you
already mentioned and we'll talk more
about
so let's stop worrying when we get close
to higher employment to say oh
inflation is just around the corner no
if there's no inflation that's visible
let's keep stimulating so this is how
the fed has changed its approach
i think the ecb could very much do the
same thing
and let's remember that in the legal
mandate of the ecb
in the treaty it doesn't say it should
only look at price stability
it said it should ensure price stability
and then
it should support the european union's
other economic goals
and those goals include full employment
they include
a socially cohesive economy it includes
protecting the environment so all of
these things are already legally
very much legitimate and indeed required
for the ecb to do so
in a sense it's even just taking full
cognizance of the mandate it already has
but that will mean continuing to shift
in this direction and giving more
support
to the economy well i have a feeling
we're going to
be hearing a lot about the european
central bank and that mandate
uh going forward but i want to bring the
debate back to the executive vice
president davskis who's with us today
you know there's a whole debate
happening in brussels about the fiscal
rules
about whether those limits that three
percent 60
dead to gdp should be changed have been
halted now because of the corona crisis
but you would have a bigger rethink
about whether that applies in the future
well indeed i think it's important to
distinguish those
two things so what we have done we have
currently activates
activated general escape clause in line
with the current
fiscal rules meaning that
in a time of severe economic downturn in
eu
or euro area as a whole exactly what we
are experiencing now
we do not set quantitative targets for
deficit and depth for member states
and what we recommend now to member
states to do is to take
necessary measures to support companies
to support workers
because what is important right now is
to preserve
as much as possible the productive
capacity of
european economy the more we preserve it
now
the faster we can recover
then of course there is a more long-term
debate which concerns
eu fiscal rules indeed we launched this
public consultation early this year and
we intend to
come back to this discussion and to
discuss
what is possible changes for eu fiscal
rules as you know already in september
last year european fiscal
board wrote a report outlining some
ideas on
simplification so sure we will expect
more debate on this but in the case
uh what will be important uh in this
discussion to preserve the right balance
between
supporting the economy and ensuring
medium and long-term fiscal
sustainability
but you do get a sense that the the
commission is open to that debate to
have it an open public debate about
whether the rules work uh well indeed we
are uh having this debate already we
launched the public uh consultation
and uh as i said we are going to return
to this uh debate
now in due time and of course
we are talking about the impact of the
corona crisis
and the other big issue has to do with
the social contract
and how the most vulnerable sectors of
society have clearly been exposed
to the coronavirus but also been hit
hard by it
so maya how can we address that social
inequality
in a way that's sufficient because we
talk about this for years and years and
years and years but how can we actually
fix it now and use this to to narrow
that gap
now i think this is exactly where it's
necessary to think about the green and
social deal and to be quite
clear about the structural trends of
trickling up
of wealth and income and unfair
development of wage levels
and a lack of a minimum wage agreement
across europe
all those have been discussed for a long
time and i think it has been now
already with the concerns about populism
that this notion of inequality
and fair chances to participate and
shape society
have come to the fore before and now we
do see that in the structural change
there is a big role for the state anyway
to support the transition in many
sectors and this is why i think all the
work that the
european commission has also been doing
in trying to set up just transition
funds and to acknowledge that it's not
only printing money
and putting it out there but also to
make sure it's got the directionality
which is the health and the environment
and the good jobs and the
upping of those jobs that we've now all
understood during the crisis are really
at the core of making people feel safe
and feel well
and at the same time to understand that
this is actually an engagement process
so the types of governance and the way
that entire regions might be able when
they're
looking at transition periods out of
basically co-dependency in some other
places in germany and other
regions in europe or when we look at
agriculture those will be very much
place based
strategies that will have to be looked
at from a more regional point of view
and so for me this whole just transition
mechanism and acknowledgement that it is
a governance
concern there as well that need for more
participation
will be essential to a make the
proposals that are already on the table
understood make them negotiated but make
them negotiate in a way that really
involves the citizens in the different
places
and not only have political
representatives and representatives of
um in most cases big corporations and
then maybe the unions depending on how
the economies are organized deal it out
we have to have much more tying back
with the population to also there regain
the trust
and i do think that it is high time to
maybe speak a bit we're talking a lot
about the future of work
but we should talk about the work of the
future also there to be clear what are
the kind of jobs that we need
to deliver on the green deal on a
healthy
well-being economy and then to
facilitate the transition and the
trainings etc in that direction
and as was mentioned before by martin we
do have a different way of looking at
spending as an investment
right now not only as an indebtedness of
states but we also should look at the
income side
because some of the concerns that were
behind the populist upswings were also
about the
inequality in the delivery or the
distribution of the burdens so
we are really now at the time when you
look again at the financial transaction
tax we can look again
at a very quick tightening of tax
avoidance
that that is being closed down on within
europe that we are really looking at
taxation
on digital corporations that we're
really looking at
where can the ones that have the wider
shoulders help contribute
making the budgets available with which
we then have to support the transition
so for me it's the two things at the
same time to look at
the bottom where we've really seen
precarious developments
but to also look at the top where we do
see that there has been a lot of
trickling up in the last 10 years and we
shouldn't repeat this
from the first dealing with the
financial crisis but be much more clear
that the money that's being used
has to get where it's needed most and
also that we have to look at
re or bringing some of the money back in
from society and not only get it from
the printing press
and executive vice president maya made a
very good point now about the politics
because this has real
repercussions on the way people vote
because they feel left out
you know very well that in the previous
crisis that created this whole
search of populism across europe how can
we avoid that
again this time around well that is
exactly the point why
the european commission is putting so
much emphasis that we not only need
green and digital recovery we also need
inclusive recovery
and addressing income inequalities
income inequalities
within countries say income inequalities
across countries
and that's one of the aims of our
economic recovery package next
generation eu to address
exactly those questions of income
equality to uh
ensure the process of convergence within
the european union
and will continue to put a lot of
emphasis on this and we'll continue to
advance our work on
social policy as i already said in
introductory remarks
uh we are currently working on action
plan to
implement european pillar of social
rights which sets
a number of principles which we want to
advance
at eu level on on
social area including on skills which
were mentioned
including currently we are working also
on a european framework for a minimum
wage and soon we'll be coming with
concrete proposals in
this area we're looking uh for example
when we discuss
as a changing a world of work uh how to
improve
the conditions of work for platform
workers
which is new phenomena and working
conditions are
often far from satisfactory how to
ensure what we call
social protection from all ensuring that
people are contributing to the social
protection system
and receiving from social protection
system uh regardless in
what kind of uh work uh contract in what
kind of uh
work relations there actually are so uh
this is uh uh something which remains
high at the commission's
priorities because indeed to how uh also
uh political uh political uh uh
acceptance uh we need to have
inclusive recovery right so i think what
you're saying it's not just the macro
this time
but also making sure that people see
that in their daily lives
and uh martin we're going to be talking
with you in
detail about this uh in a little bit but
i do want to ask you one question you
just wrote a book in which you say
we need an economy in which we we all
belong
do we not belong in the current one are
there big gaps that you feel are just
simply unsustainable over the long term
i i think yes we don't all belong
the economies don't work for everyone
and this has been very much
a long time in the making for the last
four decades you've seen increased
polarization
in pretty much all western countries
including all european
countries or virtually all european
countries income inequality has gone up
wealth inequality has gone up and
regional inequality has been going up
for for decades so instead of poorer
places catching up with
richer places typically the capital
cities we've seen the opposite now
for decades and this is a big part of
the root of the toxic politics
we've had to deal with that the pandemic
reinforces all of this
again it's the people who are already
being left behind
who are facing the greatest increase in
risk both health risk but a particular
economic risk
from everything that's happened this
year so everything that happened this
year
makes even more urgent to restore this
economy of belonging as i call it that
had already been disappearing for
decades
and just to move into the final part of
our q a the other big topic of course of
debate
is globalization is this the end of
global trade as we know it
the end of global perhaps politics a
multilateral
uh trade so i do want to ask you
executive vice president
you know when you look at the european
industries when you look at countries
like germany
france italy were important something
like antibiotics at the height of the
coronavirus many european citizens do
ask themselves
why are we not making this here why
don't we have access to it in our own
countries
so where do you see europe now on a
bigger picture scale when you look at
new industries and the industrial place
for the eu
well indeed if you look at the process
of globalization of
international trade well first of all i
would like to emphasize that from eu
we continue to defend a multilateral
rules-based international system
including in trade
at the same time we are also looking at
lessons from the crisis and developing
something which we call
a concept of open strategic autonomy
because
indeed we see that especially in health
care supplies which you mentioned
we were facing some shortcomings so
we're looking how to address them
uh whether it means more onshoring
production in europe measurements
more resilient diversified supply chains
not being
dependent on a single or very few
suppliers and this is also the broader a
concept of this open strategic
autonomy that on one hand europe remains
open for business
but at the other hand we also should be
not naive and we should be able to react
and respond if
third countries are treating our
companies our
investments in an unfair manner and
you make a very good point in which you
say we want to be autonomous but also
respect
the international trade uh rules and
multilateral is still
a big word for the european union can
you have the two at the same time be
more independent but also respect the
rules on a global scale
well there is absolutely not no
contradiction on one hand
indeed we need to respect the rules and
i think it's a world is better off if
everyone is responding
respecting the rules and that's a big
debate we are now having with a
number of uh countries uh but on other
hand
that does not prevent from looking at
what are the
weaknesses we have identified
exactly on the example you mentioned on
health uh supplies and we need to
address those weaknesses
and ensure that we are adequately
supplied especially in times of crisis
right so there is is room for that more
made in europe i guess you know
that's what you could see and uh you
know maya there's this whole digital
transition that is
uh being almost presented on a daily
basis this idea that you know we're
going to get new industries
digitalization in the form of 5g there's
also question marks
about the role that countries like china
should play
in our societies how do you view that
well i think the the key point for me or
word maybe
that was just mentioned was the european
version
because uh we've done a big report about
sustainability
and digitalization because we felt if
there is a new
powerful set of tools and technologies
being invented
right now allowing or even forcing a
transformation of our
structures of economies anyhow they
should absolutely be geared towards
solving the long-standing long-analyzed
problems that are on the social and on
the environmental side
and not create new ones and this is why
i think it is really really important
when we look at the debate and the
discourse around
digitalization and what should be in
place and not be in place to say europe
wants to have its own path because if i
look at the societal models
around the most powerful digital
companies right now
china and the us i don't think i would
like the european continent to adopt a
similar societal model with an absence
of the protection of citizens
rights to their own data with an absence
of protections against the
surveillance with a data
um collecting race basically that will
pump up more and more um environmental
pollution because we are storing all the
data instead of making some of that just
common good for example the unemp has
put forward an idea of a
planetary ecosystem so we get much more
intelligence as open source as open data
about ecosystems and their developments
how they're accessible instead of stored
on multiple servers at the same time
in different places so i think there is
a high time to really look at what are
the business models and the partnerships
with which we want to drive that
digital revolution so it can be put at
the service of solving the problems
and then we are looking at data policy i
think it is high time
to really differentiate between private
data company data then maybe some state
data and also the
publicly available one to treat a lot of
developments not as
individual apps or items anymore but as
infrastructure and then to look at how
have we been looking
at partnerships between public and
private when they're developing
infrastructures
and also at the same time to really say
how can we use this
to really inform us much better from
consumption choices to
creating the products we have to really
enabling a circular economy with a good
platform about where
are the material flows right now how can
we ensure that we get towards zero
waste patterns what's the industrial
symbiosis that's necessary what are the
data
provisions that are necessary for that
and how can they be done safely
and this is why i think it really has to
be looked at from a political economy
point of view
because the surrounding of the
technology is going to determine
what it is going to be geared at with
which interest and who's going to
benefit from it most
and uh maya you mentioned and you
mentioned it a few times in
in your remarks right now this idea of
surveillance safety
european citizens knowing exactly what's
being done with the data do you think
at this point we just don't know that
there's reasons to feel
unsafe about the way that data is being
handled right now
well i do think that we have enough
scandals to feel that there should be a
growing concern and to be
having a very open discussion about why
something like an innovation principle
shouldn't be played out against the
protection
and the irreversibility of collecting
that much data about individuals that
you do really have a chance to
affect their lives and this is what we
see with the social scoring system in
china
and i find the degree of transparency
about
what people are doing every single day
how much money they have what
health insurance they have etc in the
united states even though it's said to
be in private hands
still to a degree where it has a lot of
direct impact and we've seen a lot of
evidence of this on how are people
getting access to credit which kind of
schools do they get into
what kind of chance they have for jobs
etc etc so already we see that the use
of data
has a lot of impact about possibilities
of people leading their lives
and that should be put center stage and
not in an ideological way of either way
but to really say where is it helpful
but where do we also have to make sure
that it's not being abused
and uh martin ultimately this is really
about
trust you know this is really about
people believing
or believing the governments will work
for them
how can we do that how can we convince
them that this time
it'll be different and we are seeing
major polarization happening
right now in the global political debate
around this
well the proof is in the pudding isn't
it you have to
actually do it so people feel it on the
ground
but you quite write that trust is
important and i'd like to just echo
what commissioner dubroskis was saying
there's no contradiction between freedom
and rules it's the point of democracy
that we
collectively author rules that we then
live by but of course that does depend
on trust we need to think that our
leaders make rules in
our interest that they follow themselves
they treat everyone equally and fairly
and so on now in the in the
international or global i should say
domain that is a challenge because in
some areas we may have the same
preferences as as other countries like
china like the us
in others such as i.t we probably don't
and then we're going to have to try to
go by our rules uh
and if that means there'll be let's say
data transfers between the eu and china
so be it but coming back to the economy
really i think a lot of people are
legitimately they have lost trust all
these people who were left behind for
decades
they have good reason to say i don't
trust that you'll do what's best for me
and then it's really incumbent
upon the people who lead to earn back
that trust
how do you do that well you do that by
first of all not repeating the mistakes
of the past
don't take the foot off the accelerator
too soon and send the economy back into
recession
don't allow left behind regions left
behind
groups the young the low educated to uh
to wither on the vein as it were on the
vine
but really change your policies so that
you start helping them
i think the commission is kind of moving
in the right direction but there's
a long way from action from words to
action
and there's another way from policy
action to results on the ground so we
really have no time to lose
and uh i do want to give time to some of
the questions that we have
from our audience that's watching this
uh using the hashtag eubf2020 there's a
theme that gets repeated a lot in the
questions
uh that says this is from a user called
alfredo
how can you simultaneously protect
citizens from the covet 19 pandemic so
that is the health
aspect but at the same time stimulate
the economy so we can
emerge out of this huge crisis of big
proportions can you balance the two
the health and the economy well first of
all
it's worth noting that we are facing uh
pandemics
here and first and foremost it's a
health care crisis so we need to listen
to epidemiological advice
what we need to do to overcome the
pandemics and that's what we have been
doing in the eu and all in all we see
that we are emerging from the worst of
the crisis we are not
seeing a return to the generalized
lockdowns as we had in
spring and we gradually are seeing
economic recovery
taking place so what was important
during this
period of crisis was exactly to support
the capacity of
european economy as i said to support
european companies and
workers and this we did with the help of
large crisis package which included
sure to support the workers short-term
work teams
which included a european investment
bank
availability of loan to european
companies especially smes which
in case of need could include european
stability mechanism we allowed from
a much more flexible fiscal and stated
rule so that member states can
take action on ground and all in all we
see that
it has delivered its positive results
for example the effects on unemployment
were
not as severe as we were expecting at
the beginning
given the depth of the economic crisis
so we see that actually it
helped to preserve the employment and
now we will be putting in places
recovery package to uh to help with the
recovery
and martin i want to put that question
to you too do you think there's a way
here to balance uh both the social
health aspect of this i know you're not
a doctor but this is a big
uh component of the idea of social uh
well-being
and the economy can you do the two at
the same time
i i think it's a mistake to think that
there's a trade-off and we have to
choose one rather the other
it does seem like the economic effects
of letting the lefting contagions run
the fear and uncertainty that creates is
itself economically hugely damaging
so the lockdown the lockdowns were also
economically damaging but they were
necessary and things would probably have
been worse
without them so let's not you know let's
not deal in false trade-offs here of
course
there are difficult policy choices to
make but one
reassuring thing is that at the moment
at least
protecting individuals and stimulating
the economy point in the same direction
so the wage subsidies and short-term
working schemes we've had have sustained
people's incomes even when they couldn't
work
and that in itself is good for demand
because they can keep
buying from sectors that are still
active otherwise you would have got this
repercussions that would have made the
crisis even worse
but there are things we can do better
people who aren't in regular jobs and
who can't benefit from these schemes
have very often fallen through the
cracks so we need to
update the social security systems maybe
something like a
universal basic income style of benefit
that helps those who fall between the
cracks who are not in regular employment
or who will ultimately lose their job
anyway because let's be clear there will
be job losses
coming even though we've stayed some of
them off
and finally we really need to ensure
and encourage and pay for investment
the commission has estimated that
european companies
will lose between 750 billion and 1.2
trillion
euros this year and they make up some of
that shortfall by cutting back of
investment that's
exactly the opposite of what we need we
need to sustain investment we actually
need more investment we had too little
investment before this crisis
if you have more investment you have
more growth you have more jobs
but it's also politically easier to
direct that investment in for example
a green transition direction so
we need to continue what we've already
done we need to
spread it to more people than those who
are in regular
work situation uh work situations and we
need to get investment investment
investment going
and maya how about you what's your take
on that this is
this is a question that a lot of people
put to themselves can we can we do the
two of them at the same time
right i think i would just like to add a
thought which is
working is not necessarily always upping
demand
quite a lot of work that needs being
done right now if you want to transform
our business model
transform the products we're using
transform the technology
will mean that people have to spend time
on changing supply chains
and we have had a lot of evidence in our
research that formerly companies would
said we're
lacking the time the money or the skills
to actually do this
even though then even the economic
benefits of saving resources saving
energy
etc will be higher afterwards so to use
the kind of transfers right now to
enable people to keep on working
on changing how things are done within
the company
rather than having to up demand right
away for me is at least something that
we should very carefully and very
attentively look at because that
provides a huge opportunity
to create future value because of this
things that we're
doing having a much higher quality and
having something towards technological
leadership of what's required in the
future
people are being active they're learning
something new and
they're having an income to spend as
martin said even if the company itself
needs the kind of support
in order to be running stable have the
expenditures that they're having for
employment
whilst demand can't pick up yet so
transformation work
in itself is something that usually has
transaction costs for companies that
they're
finding hard to put up with when it's in
a normal situation
so how can we find the good coalitions
between public funds
and the private engagement towards
really then changing the types of
business models that are going to kick
start
on delivering on the demand when it
picks back up and uh
again taking questions from everyone
that's uh
watching us and and we're very happy
that you're doing this and sending your
questions of course
there's another theme that comes up
frequently and this idea of uh the eu
funding
you know that money that will come
through from the european commission
it's it's it's an agreement that's never
happened before
but there are questions about how can we
ensure that that money is used
efficiently how can we ensure that it's
used appropriately
uh well uh indeed of course when we
discuss now of
available money and overall we will have
as i mentioned 1.82 trillion
euros over the next seven years so it's
very substantial amount of
money now when we discuss
specifically the economic recovery part
of this
member states will need to prepare their
economic recovery and resilience plans
where they would need to ensure that
money is spent
in line with a common european
priorities
including green and digital transitions
that it stands in line with challenges
and
issues identified in the european
semester
where we coordinate our macroeconomic
and fiscal policy so in line also is
country specific recommendations and
we are also seeing initiatives from some
member states and from commission side
we support that
it's also spent on uh common european
projects or cross-border
projects so this is something which
member states need to prepare now and
from european commission side will be
monitoring ensuring degree of horizontal
consistency
and indeed ensuring that the money is
spent
in line with priorities we have set and
once again i would reiterate that we
also have a 30
climate mainstreaming target for both
the
next multi-annual financial framework
and next-generation uh recovery uh plan
and uh commissioner uh you know one of
the things about live television is that
we find
uh things while we're on the air and
president van der leyen has just
announced
that you will be the next trade
portfolio
uh well chief that will be uh your next
mission too so you're taking on that
trade portfolio and i just have to ask
you we have you right here with us
first of all congratulations but also
when you look at trade what's your
approach
uh going to be on that the situation
with the u.s looks particularly tricky
well uh first of all of course i would
like to thank president for the line for
uh entrusting these
responsibilities to this so i am looking
forward for taking over this trade
portfolio of course
subject to approval by european
parliament
so it's indeed an important file we are
currently
in turbulent waters as regards global
trade
relations with u.s relations with china
reform of the world trade
organization so i'm looking forward to
work on all those
important issues and you know just on
that
in terms of your approach because we are
now getting a lot of questions on this
when you now that you're the trade
commissioner against subject-to approval
what is your approach
uh going to be you've said multilateral
trade is still key for the european
union so
is that going to be your main drive and
how tough are you willing to go on some
of these negotiations well
exactly so as i mentioned we
remain committed to multilateral
rules-based
international system also in the area of
trade and probably especially in the
area of
trade so we are committed to work to the
reform of the world trade organization
and indeed there are challenges to be
addressed
there will continue to advance our
trade agreements which we are in
different stages of negotiating
and preparing with different member
states will
continue to work with investment
agreement on china
so there are many things to do and of
course it's important that while doing
all this work we uh
preserve our european approach and our
european values
and uh in terms of wto i know that you
just mentioned you still believe
in it as an organization as as trade
commissioner now
are you going to try to make it work now
because it has been very dysfunctional
for the past year
well uh obviously wto needs
a reform and from european union side we
had been proposing
already a proposals on how to reform wto
we also need to get its applet body
back to work because its nominations had
been blocked to the appellate body it's
currently not
functioning but it's important for being
able to
resolve trade disputes in an orderly
manner
but in the case we need a international
organization dealing
with a trade and therefore we need wto
and we need to reform it
and before the news broke we talked
about this idea of a european identity
and and
europe being more autonomous we're stuck
with a trade deal that could potentially
happen with china
another with the u.s are you confident
that you can
negotiate the two at the same time and
and and get to something
maybe by the end of the year uh well
uh as regards uh our negotiations with
uh us as you know we're currently rather
discussing some
uh mini deals if you want some uh
targeted uh uh targeted deals
in a sense good news is that we are
avoiding a further escalation of uh
trade
conflicts we saw uh some year and
more ago and incurs in in case of china
indeed we are working now and focusing
on
investment agreement uh of course it
would be
great if we were able to conclude it
this year but that i would say
substance before deadlines it needs to
be
ambitious agreement and indeed uh to
address
challenges and imbalances we are facing
in our investment relations with china
right so that's a good word that you
mentioned in balance that's i guess
that's where you want to take it that
you feel that the relationship needs to
be more balanced
at this point that's that's the goal and
they're aware of that the europe is is
aware that the relationship at this
point
is just not equal well and that's
exactly
a subject of negotiations we are
currently having with china we had a
round of
discussions eu china high level economic
dialogue in july where we were
discussing in-depth all those issues and
from eu side clearly also indicating the
uh
uh problems uh which still needs to be
addressed and uh i guess tough but firm
that's that's how you want to be as as a
commissioner you're going to be ready to
fly across
the world i'm sure dc may be on your
agenda
next but i do want to ask you on a
bigger picture
what is the number one priority for the
european union now i know you're taking
on more roles more
more more trade portfolios now but uh
what is the number one thing you think
we need to address at this point
well um probably if i need to say in one
word i would say
implementation because we were able to
agree
on uh substantial crisis packages and
some of them
are still to be implemented we agreed on
massive uh economic recovery plan next
generation eu
so now we need to put it properly in
place
implement make sure that this money
really reaches the economy
this money really reaches the people so
implementation of those
uh agreements of course is it's what
really matters next and
i do want to put that same question to
maya and martin when you look at the
european union at this point
what is the number one thing we just
simply have to get right now
all right i'll start with the green side
then because i do think that it is
very very crucial to uh use the
opportunity that
covet has brought to us to really
understand the connection between human
well-being and human health
and the environment and good business to
really make that the poster of this
development and to create much more
transparency in the indicators that
we're using we need
the natural capital accounting to be at
the full and we need to make sure that
this
is the competitiveness edge of the
european continent in the future
which will also lead to much more
security and resilience
i am very happy to see that there is
resilience europe
projects etc taking place next week to
really look at the policy implications
of this
is not only on medication it is also on
supply chains especially in the area of
food
we've really seen it we do see the
impacts of climate change on the
provision of natural resources to the
european economy
we're very dependent on imports we do
have geopolitical positions where it's
not so easy to bank on the continuation
of all the inputs we now take for
granted
even though the ambitions i can support
there but something like a border tax
adjustment
on carbon etc all those things come to
mind to really make sure
that we see emerging from emergence the
planetary emergence that many
organizations club of rome and bigger
alliance have been pointing out recently
needs for an economic response because
it's an utterly uneconomic development
model right now
and that this has to come out into being
a full government approach and this is
what we see with a green deal and this
is what we're really really appreciative
of
instead of it being an environmental
issue on the sidelines this is the
center
of the business model of the future well
thank you for that and we're going to
wrap this session of course i want to
say hi
and and thank you to maya to martin and
of course
to the executive uh vice president and
now trade commissioner to valdez
androskis thank you also for reacting
to that breaking news here
congratulations on on the new job i'm
sure you're going to be
very busy and as for us we're going to
now take
a ten minute break you can go make
yourself a coffee if you're at home and
also at work and then just be ready to
get back and to start voting
on the next debate which focuses on a
very contentious
issue when it comes to the economic
response to the pandemic and that is
the role of the state so please stay
with us and we will see you in a very
short bit here at the brussels economic
forum
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
now welcome back to the 2020 brussels
economic forum digital edition now this
morning we've already had
some engaging discussions and we've
already also heard
some interesting perspectives about what
kind of future we can expect
after the coronavirus and we are going
to continue
our event and in the next session we
want to know
which site you are on when it comes to a
very
thorny issue the role of the state now
our next two guests have
a very clear idea of where they stand
and they will
attempt to change your mind on what is
the most
important question or perhaps one of the
most important questions
when it comes to the handling of the
economic impact of the pandemic
so now let's begin with our poll
and let's see what you answered to the
following question
now this forum believes that an extended
role
for the state in an economy is
inevitable
and desirable after the corona virus
crisis
the question here of course is do you
agree or disagree
with the motion the vote is
open so you can grab your phone or head
to the bef
2020 webpage and vote on slider with the
quote remember
eu bef20 and tell us whether you believe
that there should be an extended role
for the state
in the economy whether that is
inevitable and perhaps even desirable
after the coronavirus crisis now we're
asking you this question
twice for a reason first of all we want
to get your gut reaction to the question
just feel the temperature of the
audience before we go
into this debate and then after once
you've heard
the arguments from our two speakers we
want to see if that debate had an impact
on your views so we really want you to
get voting on that we want to use
that hashtag we also want you to vote on
slido and then after that we'll see
whether or not
the speakers managed to change your mind
on this issue about the state
and the economy after the coronavirus
and
while you're voting which i hope you are
already i will introduce our two
speakers
now our speaker arguing in favor of the
motion
is sharon barrow she is general
secretary of the international trade
union
confederation which represents 200
million workers
in 153 countries
sharon is a passionate advocate and
campaigner for
social justice women's rights the
environment
and labor law reform
now that is for sharon you still have
time to
vote remember the question is do you
believe
an extended role of the state in the
economy is
both inevitable at this point and
desirable
given the impact of the coronavirus in
our european
economy that is the question you need to
answer are you in favor
or against and our second speaker who
will
debate this time around against that
motion of a bigger state in the economy
is professor alexander stoop he is
director
of the school of transnational
governance at the european university
institute he is joining us from
beautiful florence
and professor stoop as you know served
as prime minister of finland from 2014
until 2015
and among other positions he's also been
minister for
finance and minister for european
affairs
and trade now the way this works is each
speaker will get
eight minutes to present their arguments
in favor
and against and then a five-minute
rebuttal
now let's see if we do have some results
from our first
poll let's see if we have that you have
it on screen right there
those results which suggest that
actually
there should be a bigger state uh or a
bigger role for the state
in the economy and actually by big
numbers there's some 70 percent
so uh sharon you know take it from there
you're starting with an argument in
favor you see that the audience does
believe
there is a bigger role for the state so
sharon as i mentioned
the floor is yours well what a great
audience to start
because uh we're gonna have uh
a tough time ahead because yes it's
desirable
no question about that but is it
inevitable
tragically i think that's a matter of
political will
pre-covert you saw an incredible array
of anger and despair from people around
the world
and it was the result of a lack of
collective
will to protect people and the
environment in the face of corporate and
financial power
let's have a look at what this looked
like you had a convergence of crisis
historic levels of inequality that
wasn't just income
although that was driving a lot of the
despair it was exclusion
race gender the uh plight of uh
migrant workers glo worldwide indeed
dehumanizing supply chains in our
economic model that relied on a more and
more liberal view
of economic trade and so the
dominance of corporate interest the one
percent
and indeed of course financial uh sector
interest
included in that was pitted against
people
and against from workers point of view
decent work
but events com against communities
against those vital public services
so why do i say this we did a poll
just a week before the lockdown in
europe
and indeed 75 of the world's people
now this poll covered 56 percent of the
global population
75 percent of the world's people
actually said their incomes had
stagnated or fallen behind
that's not accidental it comes from the
role
of the economic model that people were
struggling
within we had a climate crisis
you know all about that of course
because
many of you have lost lives and
livelihoods maybe not so much in europe
but around the world because of extreme
climate events
many for working people their their
houses
their assets are becoming uninsurable
because of the risk so when you look at
a crisis of inequality a crisis of
climate and you recognize that
even then the collapse of the global
labor market
was indeed on its way 60 percent
of the world's people 60 percent of the
world's working people
actually are working in the informal
economy
no rights no decent work no rule of law
no minimum wages no social protection
that's not acceptable and why because
governments failed
to regulate and then the 40 percent of
us lucky enough to work
in uh more formal jobs or jobs with a
contract
third of those people are actually
living in precarious environments and
that's
the new areas of our economy that people
lord
we we we applaud work of any kind but
not
without the fundamental rights and
security that should go with it so
when i tell you that the new forms of
platform business or internet mediated
uh work again are informal
they have no minimum wages or income
guaranteed
often no social protection unless they
pay for it themselves
and of course they have no grievance
procedures or rule of law
particularly outside of europe so
when you look at the state of the global
labor market and they're the people
making the profits
for the one percent then i ask you
is that fair now we've heard it all from
the corporates
self-regulation we'll get it right leave
it to the market well that's
what has happened and indeed i can tell
you because i've walked those supply
chains i've walked through those
tribes of anger around the world that
people
feel despair and they feel anger and
when
more than or almost 40 percent of the
world's people have experienced
in the last two years unemployment or
reduced working hours
then pre-covert the vulnerability was
extraordinary
and we can understand why there was an
age of anger
growing against our political leaders
who didn't appear
to want to regulate the global labor
market
but indeed multilateralism was also in
tatters because people were demanding
action from their politicians so then of
course
you had covert 19. it's still with us
we'll live with it for some time to come
but the impact
has been astronomical we're living
through an historic
age of global solidarity where people
put lives first
and that's important we support that but
at the same time
recognize that the cost of that actually
has been
the loss of some 400 million jobs
in the formal sector 1.6
billion of our brothers and sisters who
with no money
each day simply don't know work each day
simply don't earn
any money 1.6 billion around the world
face destitution every day and 70
of those people have no social
protection
at all so i can tell you that the role
of the state is critical
if you're looking now at some of the
advances on the social contract that
unions and
governments and communities have made
through this crisis
including support for business
continuity where it meant jobs
and and wage protection then we can say
governments many governments have done
well although the threat of withdrawing
that support now is very very
very intense and that will throw more
people back
into that uh destitution uh frame
but what we haven't seen is really
yet outside of europe the discussion
where people
and the environment have to be put first
in a new economic frame
there are businesses who know that they
need to change
but in fact when you look again at the
reality of the unfair competition flaw
and the fight back to not regulate take
the big tech companies
that's enough the big tech companies in
fact
have made billions out of this crisis
because people have depended on the
security of online shopping
their workers are more often than not
treated without
any kind of respect or rights or social
dialogue
let alone collective bargaining or even
minimum wages
but it's the privacy that people are
concerned about as well
and when we surveyed people in this poll
then the the overwhelming majority of
people
know what they want for their
governments to act they want to see
jobs investment in jobs coming out of
this crisis
we know that those jobs have to be
sustainable
so employment and climate action are
actually joined
you know in a marriage which governments
have to respect
and yet jobs are easy if people have the
approach to investment
that is actually going to work not the
short-term
investment that came out of the last
crisis the 2809 financial crisis
where we all supported government
intervention
to save the global economy but at the
point where business felt secure again
the marriage of the bond markets and the
ratings agencies
debt simply was demanded back and
austerity was born that meant people's
jobs
wages social protection was indeed
diminished
the risk was high and in for many people
it was
real so this time we need investment in
jobs
we need investment in care and the jobs
in care
if women if progress and women are
stalled at every uh
level and indeed you see the health
crisis
because we haven't invested in our
health systems because we aren't a
resilient uh
global economy or enough in our
education systems or child care or aged
care
there are jobs in care and it's the
fabric of our communities
but there are also indeed
the support for women in those care
provisions that enable them to work more
broadly in the economy so
investment in care investment in
enabling green infrastructure investment
in repair of ecosystems
industry policy is back and as we look
at
areas of the transition that has to
happen in every sector
must be a just transition but how do we
protect and grow jobs
even as we look at the carbon border
protection
the new new rules around trade all of
the things that have to happen
this won't happen if you leave it to the
market
we also need of course investment in
skills and we must come back to wages i
said it
and i'll just repeat it the eu is in
fact the only
hope for a global floor for the for the
current environment there one or two
countries outside of the eu
doing very good things but overall the
global economy
is in free fall the global labor market
is in free fall
and we need a new approach to investment
and a new approach to debt
patient debt patient capital patient
debt
medium to long term the eu's open the
door for to that
to just transition to indeed the uh
the investment in jobs in an economic
and social sorry the social pillar of
rights and an economic future
that puts people first so desirable yes
inevitable corporate and fi and the
finance world will still argue
not all of them but unless we are
prepared to to create a fair competition
floor for those who want to involve
people
in their businesses at all levels social
dialogue
solutions for the future employment
climate
and the role of the state desirable but
for
inevitable we'll have to fight for it
and i need
you on the team because it will be
people's will
that will make the political will
possible
well sharon thanks so much for that
we've heard the arguments and now it's
time to
hear from professor sterp he is going to
argue against
that motion and professor the floor is
yours
thank you very much and good morning to
sharon and all of you from a beautiful
and sunny studio
here in florence looks like i have an
uphill battle
80 20 and it's a real tough one the
first tough choice i had to make was one
of clothing because you told me that we
have
behind me a green screen which means
nothing black
nothing blue nothing green nothing white
and nothing stripey so for a short while
there i was thinking about coming here
topless
but i thought hmm that would be pretty
good for the brussels economic
forum publicity but not good for my
chances to become trade commissioner
now i saw that valdis dombrovski's just
snitched it
so i might as well take my top off but
i'll do that a little bit later
having gotten that out of the way let me
start by saying that we
human beings have a tendency to do three
things number one
we over rationalize the past
number two we over dramatize the present
and number three we underestimate the
future
and in this spirit i will argue today
counter to sharon
that i actually think that an increased
role for the state is inevitable
in the short term but undesirable
in the long term and in order to back up
my argument
i will give you three points
point number one i am a nordic
capitalist what does that mean it means
that i believe
in the nordic welfare state as probably
one of the most
functioning economic and social systems
in the world
there are a lot of misunderstandings
about it for me
nordic capitalism is very simple it
basically means
free and open competition
driven by enterprises and entrepreneurs
who at the end of the day pay a very
high level of taxes
so that the most important part of the
economy
secondly the state can distribute that
income equally and fairly among its
citizens
so i believe in free competition and
a strong and secure welfare state
competition is taken care of by the
market
welfare is taken care of by the state
and
anyone who tries to make this into a
completely black and white argument
whereby there are only market interests
and only state interests
i think are old-fashioned marx is dead
adam smith is dead we have found a third
way
of nordic capitalism and let's stick to
it
secondly i think what we have seen in
the past
30 years is an interesting development
in the debate between
market versus state and i think
sharon is actually winning the argument
on this because remember
in 1989 the end of the cold war
the collapse of capitalism collapse of
communism and to a certain extent
old-fashioned socialism as well
it was all about market liberalization
and capitalism especially here on the
european continent
eastern and central europe even russia
were pushed to market-oriented
free movement free capitalism
reforms so that all the talk in town was
very much about
liberalization some would argue
neo-liberalism
and free market capitalism then came a
second date which i would argue changed
this and i was intimately involved first
as foreign minister later as prime and
finance minister
and that was of course the collapse of
lehman brothers
uh the sovereign debt crisis the
financial crisis which then finally
led uh to a euro crisis
in that stage the pendulum from market
swung towards state and more regulation
and who had a key role in this well of
course
eckfin and the european commission and i
think that's great
that's exactly what we needed we needed
more regulation in the financial markets
as an institutional nerd having
negotiated amsterdam this
the constitutional convention and lisbon
i would argue we would have
never gotten as far in financial
regulation as we did
was it not for the 2008 crisis
and then of course the third date is
going to be covered and has been covered
what we will see
political will or not is an increased
role for the state i think at this
particular juncture in time
it is necessary we need state
involvement
i have become overly keynesian in this
particular moment
but i think in the long run it will be
dangerous at the end of the day it's
always a balance trying to find
the proper allocation of resources
between state and market and here i come
to my third and final point
before concluding i think we really
need to move beyond this
old-fashioned almost geriatric
ideological debate between left and
right
between capitalist and socialist between
freedom and regulation
that is a world that does not exist
anymore
now the eu itself is about
the liberalization of markets it is
about the four
freedoms free movement of goods services
labor and capital
and you saw what happened in the
beginning of kovit
what did the member states want to do
they wanted to stop
all of that and immediately and they
used every argument they possibly could
to do that but what did the commission
do it fought back
and it fought back extremely well
because all
of us understand that without market
liberalization
driven by the european union national
welfare states would not be
viable or as a matter of fact they would
not
survive so the eu does the freedoms the
member states do
the redistribution the member states
provide the public goods and the level
playing field is provided by the
european union
so if market is about exclusive
competence of the european commission
in competition in the four freedoms
and in trade then i do not think
that we should in the long term destroy
that
so herefore within my eight minutes i
will conclude with the following
number one i think it's inevitable that
in the short term we will have an
increase of
state intervention and i think in a
crisis situation
that is good number two in the long term
i do not think it's desirable we have
seen that
what happens when you start closing
border and borders and when you start
taking
anti-liberal measures in the economy it
simply does not work
number three i think as a matter of fact
that what we need to do is to extend
the role of the european union and here
is where i actually agree
with sharon this is where it all counts
and then the question is
what is going to be the final balance
and let me tell you
my prediction what's going to happen
well the eu goes through three phases
first there's a crisis
second there is a chaos
and third there's a sub-optimal solution
and that's what we're gonna see again
in other words let's keep on working at
the balance between state and market
we'll never get it right but it's a good
argument to have
thank you very much well thank you for
that we have heard
your arguments both ways but this is a
time i like in a debate
this is where you get to the rebuttal
and you're gonna get five minutes sharon
to
respond to what we just heard the floor
is yours
i think to the audience we can draft
alexander
because what he said is in the short
term we do need
state intervention and we would agree
with him
on a lot of points the trade unions
fought to keep the
essential supply chains open we fought
to get
occupational health and safety
protection to frontline workers
including of course health workers but
all those transport and service and
production workers
beyond that we're still fighting that
game indeed we're fighting to get
health and safety as a fundamental right
but
no one is opposed to trade no one is
opposed
to indeed open borders certainly not the
trade unions
it's the nature of the rules that govern
them
that have become so broken now alexander
you live in the nordic paradise
and exactly your story is one that we
wish governments around the world would
heed
because indeed i'm a great fan of the
swedish economy
and your prime minister yesterday with
your uh
finance minister delivered a budget that
was all about people
but that's not the case in the rest of
the world it's not even the case in the
rest of
europe and indeed if you go back to the
swedish countries let's take sweden
because i'm there in the 1890s they're
very poor what did they do
they built social protection systems
and everybody had a sense of security
yes they pay high taxes and indeed we
support that because they built their
wealth collectively
off the base of of shared prosperity
now if that was the model for the rest
of the world i think alexander and i
could sit down
in good old fashion social dialogue
whether he's the
trade commissioner now or in the future
or foreign minister or whatever his
future is
and actually talk with our colleagues on
both sides
and the employers who want a different
future
what it looks like but in the if we do
not if we do not put the
the rule of rights the social pillar
people's right to a minimum living wage
to collective bargaining
to actually have the grievance
procedures the rule of law
that protect them from exploitation if
we do not put
the just transition measures in place
where no one is left behind
workers communities and if we do not
look to a future that is absolutely
balanced between an economic future
but the role of people within it and i
don't
mind what the ideology is that people
put around it but
people first is what we have to have
from our governments
and how you build an economy that serves
them i'll tell you what i'm facing
today today i'll address the un finance
ministers
on thursday the labour ministers of the
g20
and we've asked for you know the rules
of the game to be enforced it's true
but we also want to see one thing
one thing those seventy percent of
people without any social protection
worldwide imagine that and some of them
by the way
even exist in that state within
developed countries
but we want for the poorest and most
vulnerable in what's already a 10
trillion dollar spent
way beyond the eight to nine crisis and
we'll probably double that by the time
we can build a more secure future at
least see the hope of it
indeed we want around 35 billion a year
collectively
globally for the poorest and most
vulnerable countries
to indeed establish universal social
protection
this shouldn't be a battle but it's
indicative
of the lack of coherence indeed around
the issues that alexander raises but
around the issues that concern people
jobs wages the right to bargain
collectively
the commitment to social dialogue the
rules of the game that break up
monopoly power governments workers
employers and community in the fight
against
climate but in the fight for rights are
critical
and i would say to you that if you want
one piece of example of what's wrong
with our world
i read those stories about russia and
america spying on each other about
vaccine technology why on earth
can't we work together as governments to
see there is a vaccine against this
insidious virus
for everybody the interdependence of a
world
alexander paints is indeed
about everybody if one country if one
people are sick
then the the trade that he talks about
will shut down
so we're in trouble global demand slump
jobs are
you know a dream for many many people
minimum wages
collective bargaining these things are
the tools for trade unions to share
prosperity and yet they're under threat
everywhere but in the end it's about
jobs
it's about climate action that is just
and indeed
it's about wages and social protection
that's what will give people hope and
i'll finish with
a statistic that will shock you but
those people uh you know two-thirds of
the people who tell us what they want
which is the things i've talked about
vital public services
you know taxation where corporations
actually pay their tax
rights jobs climate action etc
of those people they feel excluded
from the voice that governments listen
to
think about that and what it means for
our democracy if we don't rebuild
a very different future where people are
at the center
and the economy serves people then and i
think
alexander frankly is in this frame
no one is arguing about the rules of the
game
in terms of global trade except that it
can't not be mindless
and it cannot be at the cost of
exploitation of workers
or indeed their countries while dominant
nations win
every time okay well we've heard the
arguments
alexander how do you respond to that you
have also five minutes
here's my classic rebuttal uh in three
points
starting by saying it's wonderful sharon
that you want to draft
me as well i'm an avid cyclist
watching the tour de france doing a lot
of work
against headwind i think we can find a
common tone
point number one i am not in the nordic
paradise i am
in a florentine paradise here in
florence and secondly
i am not swedish i am finnish but yes i
do have a swedish name
and yes my mother tongue is sweded and
yes i do
love our swedish neighbors as well
and i do agree with you i think there
are a lot of good things with
nordic capitalism or nordic welfare
states where
those to be able to be adapted on a
european or otherwise level
i think many of us would be better off
my point number two is to avoid
polarization and this is what i'm really
worried about and sharon i
understand you have to push the bucket
of the trade unions
but i make a pledge to you and make an
argument that the way in which we work
is different from the way in which our
markets
and our societies were established many
decades ago
and we all need to adapt to that and if
we use
language whereby we talk about exclusion
dehumanization movements against
liberal trade dominance of corporates
pitted against the workers and
communities
i think we're barking up the wrong tree
there are people on the extreme
right that use that method there are
people on the extreme left that use that
method
what i want to see in the survival of
trade unions and
industrialists is that you guys start
cooperating
not pitting yourself against each other
if you want facts which you said i give
two recommendations
not only to youtube at all to the all
listeners one is
hans rusling swedish now for
unfortunately late
uh medical doctor uh
his book factfulness please read it this
world is a hell of a lot better off
than what it was a hundred years ago 50
years ago or 10 years ago
and secondly stephen pinker's
enlightenment now and i don't say this
only
because i am in the city of renaissance
to all youngsters out there who are
looking
at their job careers or to all parents
who have youngsters who are thinking
about it
i finish off by giving three pieces of
advice
for the future of work i have a 16 year
old son
and an 18 year old daughter their life
expectancy
is almost 110 years i do not foresee
their careers being with the
workers against the industrialists they
are most probably throughout their life
going to be self-employed in different
types of formations in jobs
we don't even know what they're going to
be like in the future
so when they go into this world and when
they go and study
they need three things number one they
need
to learn how to analyze the world the
world
is not an education is not about
memorization
it is about analyzing and connecting
different types of dots number two they
need to learn how to take care of
themselves
and by that i mean that they're going to
be in a stressful career path
whereby they need to take care of both
their body
and mind throughout their lifespan
and number three and this is most
important and i'm sure that sharon will
agree
with this as well we're moving towards a
world
where robots and algorithms are
increasingly doing tasks that we used to
do
both physical in the factory or
otherwise
and mental at your office where for
instance all of us
are information managers standing in
front of a screen
what is the most important asset that
you have
as a human being it is empathy
the way in which you connect and relate
to another human being so let's try to
avoid
all of this juxtaposition black and
white
pitting market against state think about
things a little bit more broadly
and do it through empathy thank you very
much
well thank you so much to you both uh
thanks for those arguments and we've
also established that alexander stoop is
finnish he's not swedish
which um that's also key but um on a
serious note and now going back to
our debate on our panel we want to put
back that question we want to bring back
the
slido poll for a second time and get
your views
so remember the question was should the
state have a bigger role
in the economy is it inevitable is it
desirable remember you can
vote on slido that's s-l-i-d-o
and use the code e-u-b-e-f so get voting
on that
and while you're voting let's just
remind ourselves of why the state
or the role of the state has become such
a big issue during
this pandemic we've seen states across
the world responding
to the crisis by acting to protect jobs
incomes businesses in this unprecedented
time
with kuvin 19 we're expecting that 71
million people could be
pushed into extreme poverty worldwide
so how could they not take action when
you come to europe you do see about
2060 000 companies across europe
that could also face financial
difficulties as a result
of the crisis and these companies employ
around 25
to 35 million people now governments
across
europe supported by the european union
are spending
billions of euros on temporary wage
subsidies
to avoid those mass layoffs which also
clearly show
that the state is gaining importance but
the question is
whether these are just extraordinary
measures and extraordinary times
and therefore temporary in nature or
whether we're seeing
a permanent change in the role of the
state
in the economy after all because of the
lockdown european businesses
now stand to lose about 720 billion
euros this year alone
and that is more than the annual
economic output
of finland and austria combined now how
easy will it be for governments to wind
down such
support a lot will depend on the
strength of the recovery
but it's an expanded role of the state
desirable
governments have already spent and we've
seen debt in europe reached
new record levels and as the previous
crisis
did taught us at one point that could
pose
a risk to the economy and prove
unsustainable
over the long term so you have to keep
all of this
in mind now let's try to see if we have
those votes coming through if you have
been
voting on that remember the question was
should
the state have a bigger say in the
economy
should it not and we see that 60 percent
of you 60
of everyone who voted in this poll
actually agrees
the state should have a bigger say in
the economy and it's inevitable so thank
you so much to everyone
who voted we appreciate your point of
view on this and we appreciate taking
the time of course
uh to uh vote in this debate
and also i want to thank sharon and
alexander strip for
before that participating in it and you
know was
it was interesting to say the least so
thanks for that
and now for our next segment i'm
happy to hand it over to sasha vaquelina
from euro news and she will be
joined by another special guest that is
commissioner paolo gentilani who will be
taking questions
from you and you know if you want to get
your question
to the commissioner make sure again that
you go on slido that you use
uh that hashtag that we're using and
that you put it
to us so we can pass it on to the
commissioner sasha will do that for you
so grab your phone
head to the bef 2020 website send those
questions
on twitter or on slido use that code
e-u-b-e-f sesh as i mentioned we'll make
sure that the commissioner
gets those questions and let me now
welcome
commissioner paola gentilani and i will
give
the floor to to sasha before i see you
back
after a very short break
[Music]
hello and welcome to our next session my
name is sasha vaquelina i'm euro news
business editor and i'm very pleased to
be hosting this
brussels economic forum conversation
with our next
guest european commissioner paolo
gentiloni mr gentiloni
is the italian commissioner in the
wonderland commission where he is in
charge of the
economy portfolio in less than a year as
european commissioner he has
had to face an unprecedented number of
challenges probably
more than some of his predecessors faced
in their five-year terms and among of
course some of the key tasks for the
european commission and commissioner
gentilone in particular
have been the launch of the green deal
the suspension of the stability and
growth packed the creation of the shore
instrument to protect
workers and of course the recovery
package agreement and the presentation
of the next
generation eu proposal in our interview
we will be discussing these and are the
key issues for the future of the eu
economy including the role of the state
fiscal policy and the green
transition let me remind our viewers
that you can send your questions on
slide
now or join the conversation in twitter
just enter
sli dot d o in your browser and use the
code
hashtag eubaf 20.
commissioner gentlemen thank you for
being with us today at the brussels
economic forum
pleasure thank you and indeed what
extraordinary
period we experienced absolutely and let
me just follow up on something that's
been closely linked to the debate that
we've just
heard and followed together here a bit
earlier on the role of the state in the
economy in the five
biggest european economies alone and
that is germany france britain
italy and spain 45 million people
had their wages partially covered by the
state to keep them
in jobs does this mean an expanded role
for the state in the economy is
inevitable and desirable
after the coronavirus crisis
well let me recall that
robert lucas the american nobel prize
winning economist said i guess
everyone is a keynesian
in foxhole and by the way he was not
keynesian
back to your question yes my answer is
definitely
yes the role of the unexpanded role of
state is
first inevitable just think
to the employment consequences
figures that eurostat
delivered a few minutes ago are showing
how
strong the impact in employment
is despite the effort of all member
states and despite this extraordinary
new initiative
proposed by the commission that we call
sure
it is also desirable because if we want
to reorient
our economies towards the digital and
green transition
we need a strong role for the state
but we have to add that it is also
challenging
because not only because obviously
this expanded role should not
come to to replace
the private sector but also
because the expanded state aid
should not disrupt the level playing
field
in the single market we have different
strengths from different member states
and if we don't have rules on state a
this could enhance the divergence
inside the single market and finally
uh very clearly a stronger role of the
state
has nothing to do with models of
authoritarian capitalism that we are
looking outside the union
and sometimes with some temptation also
inside the union
the role of the state in the economy is
also very closely linked to the ongoing
discussions
on the fiscal rules of course and the
general
escape clause and the economic
governance review
what are the commission's plans with the
state aid flexibility and the general
escape clause
how long will this remain in place and
should we rethink
the way we approach that
well of course we will go back to
common rules so
both the temporary framework for state
aid
and the generous escape clause are not
forever
we have two important decisions to take
one is the timing because it's
absolutely crucial to avoid
to go back to tightening rules
too soon we need to give our economy
the necessary time and this means
that we need in 2021 to keep
a positive fiscal stance in
our economies and second
what kind of rules we were lucky because
we were already
having a review of our six-pack and
two-pack regulations
and i think that this review this
discussion would be very interesting to
update the rules of
to the post covered situation
and i want to move to one of the top
priorities of
this commission which is of course the
green and digital
transition and how this will be linked
to the recovery plans of the member
states
reaching the 2030 climate and energy
targets will require
additional investment of 260 billion
euros
a year by 2030
decalizing europe will cost 4.6 trillion
euros that is 18 times the cost of the
apollo program
that put the first man on the moon
yes are you confident we can reach that
what will be the role of the recovery
instrument in that
yes by the way we could make another
comparison
the recovery uh package and the marshall
plan
in fact the recovery package in the
countries where you have you can have
this comparison with the marshall plan
is even bigger of the mark than the
marshall plan but
in any case i think that the task
is very very hard
but the european leadership is
absolutely necessary uh who else
what what other uh international
uh political actor apart from the
european union
could play a leadership role in the
green transition
nobody to be honest at least
not in this moment so we have to bring
this
uh task to its goals
and to do this we need to
coordinate all the national recovery and
resilience plans to this priority
we are fixing a threshold of 37 percent
of each national recovery plan
dedicated to environmental and climate
initiative a very high threshold and
then
we need to facilitate public investment
and the
and here we are back to the fiscal rules
we will need
in our discussion on the new common
physical rules to find ways to
facilitate public investment especially
for our twin transitions
and the last but not least before we go
to the audience questions i want to
zoom in on the recovery package with you
we're still going to be below the 2019
gdp
levels at the end of this year and the
rebound will be
uneven as you've said what else can the
eu
and the member states do to boost the
recovery will the recovery package
be enough and are you satisfied with the
agreement
of the leaders well i'm quite satisfied
you are never fully satisfied because
there are always things lacking
and i perfectly understand the european
parliament
saying that on some goals
the agreement was dismissive
but overall i think it is an
extraordinary agreement
and so our first task is implementation
i would say we are lucky to have the
german presidency
in this semester because i'm sure that
the german presidency will be very
active and effective
in helping this implementation
politically
because we need ratification of several
parliaments
and also on the content on the
technicalities
a lot of work has to be done and second
we need the quality
of the recovery plans because
well the commission is not a financial
intermediary we are not raising money in
the markets
and transferring this money to national
governments
of course national governments have the
ownership of the recovery and resilience
plans
but these plans should be coordinated
with our common goals and this is a
really fascinating task
for the commission and for the member
states in the next few months so
implementation quality of the programs
and then new initiatives especially on
own resources and among these the carbon
boarded adjustment which is
i think a crucial mechanism if you are
serious on this green transition
let's now go to the questions from the
audience of course i've got to remind
you that as for the previous sanchez
sessions you can ask them via slider
using the code and you can do it on
twitter with the hashtag eubaf20 and
some of the questions we're receiving
there's a recurring theme among all of
them is the social impact
of the crisis the viewer asks if there
should be an eu framework to guarantee
an adequate
minimum income and decent minimum
wage so this is one of the biggest
concerns with the question that we have
been receiving during our conversation
what's your take on that well the social
dimension was
key in our first reaction i just
reminded sure
and we are now ready with this sure
program which is
distributing 100 billion
and on top of the national schemes
this is very clear if we compare the
european situation to the u.s situation
yes we had consequences in our labor
market
unemployment and especially employed
people
decreasing but nothing comparable to
what happened
in america in the last weeks
this sure was a big effort something we
were discussing
since 12 years and that we decided in
two months
and then we are working especially my
colleague nicolas schmidt
is working on the minimal wage
we know it's not easy because of
difficulties both
in countries where the social situation
is not advanced
and also on the contrary in countries
where the social situation
the i mean the social welfare is very
advanced
in both group of countries there is a
sort of skepticism but i think this is
the right moment to try to have minimum
wage
in europe another question from the
audience
one of our viewers boris would like to
know how the commission can ensure that
the national recovery plans are in line
with the eu priorities and how will you
make sure the governments will
implement reforms and not just cut taxes
well we can be sure for the simple
reason that
we are the one the commission supposed
to
propose to the council
the implementation the approval
of these plans the process means that
we are discussing in the next month
these plans with
member states and stressing the
ownership of national governments and
parliament
but it will be a dialogue at the end of
this dialogue
beginning of next year we will propose
to the council the approval of these
plans
so here is our task and the possibility
to respect our priorities
i've got another question on taxes on
taxation this is something that seems to
be a very important and interesting
issue for our viewers and everybody
who's following of course
the brussels economic forum live uh
on the role of the taxation and the way
what can it play in this transition in
particular
several people asked about how the role
of digital taxation and
green taxes is reaching the goals for
the transition
in general i think it's very important
because if we
are issuing a common debt and if we
establish that this common debt should
be repaid from
2026 to 20 50 66
30 years but the beginning of these 30
years
is five or six years from now
how will we repay this will we
ask again to member states through the
their gni to repay this debt
or will we be able with new owned
resources
and also digital taxation and green
taxation
to repay i think that the first
scenario is a failure for the union
and the second one is the success and so
we are working very hard on all
resources
to to obtain this success
and the final question from the audience
because we have to unfortunately wrap it
up
we could carry on we've got so many
questions of course from the viewers
online
uh our audience wants to hear more about
how the recovery fund will support small
and medium size companies that's of
course a great question given the fact
that smes are
definitely the backbone of the european
economy and some of them seem to be
concerned about the cuts agreed by
leaders to the invest
eu program some of those businesses what
do you think about that
yes indeed it's one of the decision that
we are regretting as commission the fact
that invest
eu was not strengthened at it should
have been
but indeed this window for small and
medium enterprise
remains in the invest eu and
recently we added to this
a strong recapitalization of the
european investment bank
that allows to the eib programs for
with 200 billion euros in support to
small and medium enterprises
so it's not perfect but we have new
tools
also in this direction thank you so much
commissioner paul and gentlemen for this
conversation and thanks to everybody
following us online and asking those
questions thanks a lot for this
conversation
thank you well thank you
to uh commissioner gentilani grazie
comisario
and to sasha vaquelina for that
insightful discussion
and moving on we want to move to the
final part
of our event here and our closing
speaker
is a politician who spent a very long
few nights here
in july when he was working on a very
tough negotiation and succeeded in what
is a not so easy task
agreeing and getting 27 heads of states
to agree on that historic
recovery plan for europe and i am of
course referring to the president of the
european council
xia michelle and president michelle of
course is an experienced politician
who served as prime minister of belgium
from 2014 to 2019
before being elected head of the
european council last year
so president michelle is a pleasure to
have you with us today here at the
brussels economic forum
the floor is yours thank you maria and
thank you to
everyone watching and listening and
thank you paulo for
inviting me to this forum a major event
for european
economic debate indeed in july european
leaders
reached a deal on our next budget and
our recovery plan it wasn't easy
but it was a success in fact it was such
a success
that requests for me to speak have
multiplied by 20.
of course this achievement belongs to
the european leaders
and most importantly to europe as a
whole
this agreement was a major step to our
vital objective european strategic
autonomy
european strategic autonomy because
before the summit
many people were skeptical that a deal
was possible
but i was determined to make it happen
i was so determined to reach a deal that
when journalists
asked me how many days the summit would
last
i told them if necessary i'm ready to
ask the belgian prime minister
i know her very well to close all the
belgian airports
and after four days and four nights we
reached a deal and you know that
no airports were closed
why was success at this first summit so
critical
we had to act quickly and decisively
because uncertainty is damaging
think back to commentary before the
summit
it's true european leaders had divergent
views
some challenged the union's borrowing
and financial markets
to support member states with grants
some thought the amounts were too high
others thought they were too low and
at the start of the pandemic europe was
criticized
for reacting too slowly in fact
the reality was tried the opposite
compared to the great financial crisis
europe took charge with exceptional
strength
and speed precisely because we learned
the hard
lessons of that crisis and decision
makers
both at national and eu level
recognized the urgency and touch
the difficult decisions europe's overall
economic response
has been far superior to the stimulus
packages
of the united states or china and this
board european response was fundamental
to protect our citizens
and safeguard our businesses the
financial markets have also recognized
our comprehensive action but
let's remember the atmosphere back in
june and july
enormous expectations were rising the
pressure
was building and so were the doubts and
uncertainty and while uncertainty
is a political risk it's also an
economic one we know that the impact of
economic shocks can last
long after the clauses have been
addressed
for example depressing the labor market
and
eroding skills associated with prolonged
unemployment but there are other ways
a crisis can undermine long-term growth
such as undermining confidence
as companies lose trust in the future
the appetite for risk decreases so
does the appetite for investment in key
areas
like innovation and employees are less
keen
to develop new skills it was therefore
crucial
to act quickly but also with
strength and with unity and
that's exactly what we did in july with
one strong clear response to this
unprecedented crisis
in the spirit of our founding fathers
in fact this was a thirst for europe in
many ways the first time the european
union will borrow to invest into reform
the first time such a jaw-dropping
amount over 1.8 trillion euros
has been negotiated for europe and the
first time
a major part of the eu budget is linked
to our climate ambitions
and the first time our budget will be
linked
to the rule of law and that's not all
we also committed to creating new own
resources during the next budgetary
period
a few words about this establishing
these new resources
is of the utmost importance not only
because
creating new substantial revenues will
be an irreversible step
in strengthening the union's capacities
not
only because environmental taxation will
make a pivotal contribution
to our carbon neutrality goal for 2050
in my opinion it's much more than that
we will not accept that environmentally
substandard
goods unfairly compete with european
products while at the same time
damaging the planet and we are ready to
establish a carbon board adjustment
mechanism in line
with an improved emission trade system
to protect
our level playing field if foreign
companies
want access to our market we expect them
to be on the same footing
as our european companies we are sending
a message not only to our citizens
but also to the rest of the world europe
is a world power and we are ready to
firmly defend our
interests this is what we showed in july
but of course important steps remain to
get this agreement
over the finish line the european
parliament's consent
and the ratification by member states
and then comes the hard work because
this recovery plan is not just
a simple stimulus plan in my opinion
it's much more than that it's a
transformation strategy that will lead
us
to the europe of the future this is
a copernican moment this strategy will
build
on its two main pillars the dream deal
and the digital agenda we enforced by an
industrial plan for a more independent
europe
and to make this strategy sustainable we
will modernize
our fiscal rules and we
never forget what underpins these plants
our unique set of european values
it's the why behind
all our actions to make our societies
stronger
fairer and more resilient
the green deal will protect our planet
and our quality of life
while creating wealth and increasing our
well-being
europe's digital strategy will unlock
the promise of technology
and improve the lives of our citizens
while respecting their fundamental
freedoms
our industrial strategy will foster
greater independence
and make sure we have access to all the
necessary resources to ensure
the prosperity of our citizens this
includes for instance
greater autonomy in producing processes
vital medicines and other essential
products
finally our fiscal rules these rules
give member states the capacity to act
in hard times
current 19 has shown the pivotal role of
the state
in protecting livelihoods and businesses
but we must remain vigilant
there is no magic money as we implement
our recovery plan
every euro must be used thoughtfully
and efficiently european plan
is not a three or seven year strategy
it's a 30 year strategy our prosperity
will be founded on democratic and human
values
and for this to work we need trust
as a law student at the free university
of brussels
a long time ago i was strongly
influenced by a professor her name was
nelly schmitz
she offered a schumpeter workshop as
part of her political economy class
and i never forgot her words innovation
and progress go together we all know
that confidence is the key to democratic
legitimacy
confidence is also key to transforming
our economies and our social model vital
to making the success
of our climate and digital transitions
dear friends we believe in our future
and we are sending one clear message
europe is united and confident
entered in our values europe projects
power
and we are ready to act to transform our
economic and social model
with one constant goal greater benefits
for
our citizens european strategic autonomy
a repeat european strategic autonomy
these are not just words the strategic
independence
of europe is our new common project
for this century it's in all
our common interests 70 years
after the founding fathers european
strategic autonomy is
goal number one for our generation
for europe this is the real start
of the 21st century thank you
well thank you president michelle for
taking the time to be
here with us today at the brussels
economic forum
and i have to say we've reached the end
of our event you know this is the sad
part
but it's been a busy morning we've
certainly had a lot of interesting
discussions happening here
and we're certainly going to continue to
talk about those issues certainly on the
minds of decision makers
here in brussels in the few months to
come
i also want to thank each and every one
of our speakers
for taking the time today and our media
partners your news
and the financial times and i also
really want to thank
especially you the audience for tuning
in
and really all of your participation i'm
in fact being told
that at one point we've been 15 000
people watching at the same time
and all of your questions all of your
feedback we're really appreciated and
you know we really hope to do this again
next year
in a more usual in-person format
but certainly still retaining that
discussion our speakers
and that audience participation and now
everyone of course
have registered for that exclusive live
session with martin samtwoo from
the financial times you would have
received a link to that so
connect on that and the session will
start at 12
o'clock you'll be able to submit some
questions so get your camera and your
microphone ready
and to the rest of you again many thanks
for making this
20th anniversary of the brussels
economic forum
so special we'll see you next year in
2021 and i also want to take this
opportunity to thank everyone
at dg finance the whole team staff crew
technicians
that made this possible thank you so
much take care stay safe
we'll see you next year
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you